In order to look at planning in detail, let us consider this problem that we
have encountered earlier. This is a blocks world, in which there is
a robot which has to move the blocks from the current state, to the goal state.
The robot has only one arm, so it can move only one block at a time.
It can move only a block which does not have some other block on top of it.
Earlier, when we considered this method, we had looked at weak AI methods like
means-ends analysis. Now we're going to look at more systematic,
knowledge-based methods. One question unanswered in our previous discussion was,
how can we find which goal to select, among the various goals that are here?
They simply said, the agent might select a goal.
Now we will look at how the agent can in fact do the goal composition and
select the right goal to pursue?